[Music]
so if you have a history that goes back
quite away as a true Johnny and maíam
you work together as kids on the show
blossom genre guest star we were we were
we were both 14 right we kissed
first pitch yeah it was both your first
stage kiss yeah
it might have been my first real life
kiss all do it again now show is this
Kunal knows what to say always knows has
the right thing always the right thing
at the right time we actually found a
picture of it you guys do look like
going in I let your move going in there
various very help that pose how did you
nicer blouse was there any connection
there at all where did you guys become
friends after this stage kiss or die for
a second we were
[Applause]